- Season eight of HBO's "Game of Thrones"
has come to an end, and a lot
of people, including myself,
are pretty annoyed
about how it played out.
In this video, I'm going to
break down the main reasons
why fans were left so disappointed
by what was supposed to
be a fitting conclusion
to one of the greatest
TV shows of all time.
No. 1, it was rushed.
Everything in season eight
seemed to be happening
too quickly, and it would often feel like
three episodes worth of information
was being crammed into one
feature-length episode.
A side effect of this
was that we weren't able
to enjoy the big payoff moments
in the way that we had previously.
For example, in episode
one of season eight,
Jon rode Rhaegal.
This is something that
has huge significance,
but it didn't feel like a big event,
and the reason is it came
halfway through an episode
where loads of other really
important things happened.
Jon was reunited with Bran and Arya,
Theon saved Yara, the Golden
Company arrived in Westeros,
Ned Umber was killed by the White Walkers,
Jaime Lannister turned up
unannounced at Winterfell
and had a stare-off with Bran,
and Jon actually learned
that he was Aegon Targaryen,
heir to the Iron Throne and
nephew of his lover, Dany.
Yeah, a lot of stuff
happened in that episode.
When you compare this moment to when
Daenerys first flew with Drogon,
it pales in insignificance.
It was the climax of
season five, episode nine,
and was part of a tense
nine-and-a-half-minute scene
where Daenerys was ambushed
by the Sons of the Harpy
in the fighting pits of Meereen.
Drogon, who was previously missing,
swooped down to protect Dany
before she climbed on
its back and flew away.
The early seasons of "Game of
Thrones" were dialogue-heavy,
building up characters,
and there wasn't much on-screen action.
Season eight, and to some
degree six and seven,
were not like this at all.
No. 2, character development.
Something that seemed
like a direct consequence
of the rushed nature of season eight
was the jarring character
development, which left viewers
feeling shocked, confused,
and even betrayed.
Many would argue that
the show lost its way
from season five onwards.
That was the point that Benioff and Weiss
started making the biggest departures
from George R.R. Martin's books,
but season eight has had
by far the most backlash.
Here's why.
Each and every character
had been painted so vividly
up until this point,
and within six episodes,
some had changed beyond recognition,
and the best example of
this is Daenerys Targaryen.
We had seven seasons of Daenerys Targaryen
being built up as one of
the main heroes in the show,
and she was torn down and destroyed
in the final three episodes.
Many fans of the show felt betrayed by it.
I just want to make it
clear that this isn't me
criticizing the story arc.
If it was necessary for Dany
to become the Mad Queen,
then that is fine,
but it should not have
happened so quickly.
I think I could have gone
along with her downfall
if I was subjected to
at least three episodes
of her decline following
the death of Missandei.
I feel like we needed
to see her not eating,
not sleeping, and growing more and more
paranoid and vengeful.
Instead what we got was a
few shots of her looking
a bit tired with bags under her
eyes and her hair messed up.
This just wasn't good enough.
When the bells rang out
around King's Landing
and Dany decided to burn
down the city anyway,
killing thousands of
people in the process,
it just didn't feel like a decision
that the Daenerys we'd followed
for eight season would make.
OK, let's move on to Jon.
Jon had the most screen time
throughout the whole show
and probably the most
interesting character arc
out of anyone else,
the secret son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark,
the man who is an actual
mixture of ice and fire.
What was the point of
Jon being a Targaryen?
The big reveal of this
information was a huge part
of the narrative, yet it
was only used as a tool
to partly justify the descent
of Daenerys into madness.
Finally on character development,
let's look at Jaime
Lannister, the Kingslayer.
Season one's most-loathed character
was transformed throughout eight seasons
as we learned more and more about his past
and saw him perform
noble and selfless acts.
This all peaked when he deserted Cersei
to go and fight at
Winterfell to save Westeros
from the Night King and
the Army of the Dead.
After this, he again deserts
a lover, Brienne this time,
to go and save Cersei,
but this move isn't quite
the selfless act that the previous one was
and actually reduces
a lot of the hard work
that was put into building him up.
Were we supposed to think
that this commitment
to his sibling was noble?
It certainly didn't seem it.
Three, anticlimactic moments.
By far, the biggest
anticlimactic moment for me
in season eight was the
death of the Night King.
Yes, the battle was huge
and cinematically beautiful,
when you brightened it up a little bit,
but it wasn't what some
"Game of Thrones" fans
were waiting for. Here's why.
The opening scenes of
season one, episode one,
showed members of the Night's
Watch going beyond the Wall
and coming face-to-face
with a White Walker.
The side narrative throughout the show
was that the wars between
wannabe kings of Westeros
were actually nothing
compared to the threat
that was building beyond the Wall.
When we were introduced to the Night King,
he immediately became
the ultimate villain,
incredibly powerful and
seemingly undefeatable.
So when this enemy was defeated
midway through season eight,
it seemed like a bit of an anticlimax,
not to mention the way
in which it happened.
First of all, we didn't get
the see any of the skilled
swordsmen battling the
Night King nor his henchmen.
I just want to make it
clear, I have no problem
with Arya being the person
who killed the Night King.
I actually really liked this,
but we were teased this main event
of Jon and the Night King having a battle.
He didn't get to fight him at Hardhome.
He didn't get to fight him on the lake,
and it just felt like
the Battle of Winterfell
was where it was going to happen,
yet what we got was Jon chasing him around
and being blocked by an undead dragon,
and the Night King not fighting anyone
and then being killed
without a battle by Arya.
It just felt a little bit
like an anticlimax to me.
Another anticlimax for myself
was the death of Cersei and Jaime.
The story arc of the sibling lovers
threatened more than once to
end in betrayal or murder,
but in the end, the two
were killed by falling rocks
while trying to run away from Daenerys
and Drogon's fire frenzy on the Red Keep.
A little bit of a letdown.
Another anticlimax was Jon ending up
back at the Night's Watch.
I know this is a circular story
and George R.R. Martin does like those,
but it didn't feel like it was
what his character deserved.
Jon had an epic storyline with
his true heritage revealed
as Aegon Targaryen, but
it all came to nothing,
and he found himself back at Castle Black
going ranging with the wildlings.
Despite Arya killing the Night King,
I do feel like she was
underused in this series.
Since killing the Freys, we never saw her
use her faceless training again,
which could have been for
some more interesting viewing
than seeing her ride off
on a random white horse.
It was pretty anticlimactic for myself
that the Unsullied and
the Dothraki just left.
The final episode shows the
Unsullied and Dothraki armies
hyped for more wars at the start
but ends with them leaving in boats,
watching the person who killed their queen
walk past without doing anything.
They say time's a healer, but I'm not sure
it works wonders like that.
Four, plot holes.
Season eight was "Game of
Thrones"' final season,
so all of the loose ends
should have been tied up,
and the audience shouldn't be
left asking questions, right?
Wrong.
Here are just a few that
are keeping me up at night.
So what about Bran becoming the king?
As much as I personally like this twist,
it was a little unbelievable
due to the way that it happened,
especially when all the people deciding
seem to have a far more obvious choice.
Tyrion loves stories, right?
And who had a better
story than Bran Stark?
How about Jon?
Jon went from Stark
bastard to Lord Commander
to King in the North.
He was literally killed and resurrected.
He was the Prince that was Promised
who slayed his lover for
the good of the realm.
Now, let's send that
guy to the Night's Watch
where he can watch over what, exactly?
No one even talked about
him as a possibility
when they were choosing the
next leader of Westeros.
The reason for this: It
was part of an agreement
to please the Unsullied and Yara Greyjoy,
who felt that Jon should be
punished for killing Daenerys.
While this is understandable
to a certain degree,
it feels hollow as the Unsullied are seen
minutes later boarding a
ship to the Isle of Naath,
and the Greyjoys were not a
powerful-enough house to demand
this sort of respect from
the other lords of Westeros.
Sansa and Arya both had great stories
worthy of becoming queen, but again,
neither of them were mentioned.
So Bran became king, but
how can the Three-Eyed Raven
actually become king anyway?
Bran went from this
strange, emotionless person
who would stare blankly
before saying something
that made others feel uncomfortable
to the king of Westeros,
and none of the characters
even batted an eyelid.
The last Three-Eyed Raven
lived north of the Wall
and merged with a tree.
Why is Bran so different?
That's just another thing
that isn't explained.
Who is the Prince of Dorne,
how did he come to power,
and why are the Martells
suddenly so unimportant
in season eight despite
being such a big focus
of earlier seasons?
And finally, why does the
Night's Watch even exist anymore?
The White Walkers are wiped
out, wildlings are allies,
the Wall is destroyed near East Watch,
and various castles along
the Wall are unmanned.
Is there any point in restoring them?
Five, forgotten characters.
It became very clear in the final seasons
that a few characters
really served no purpose
to the final outcome of the show.
Where's Jaqen H'ghar?
The Faceless Man is one of the characters
who trained Arya Stark.
At the end of season six, he
let her go back to Westeros,
and we haven't heard from him since.
What about Daario Naharis?
The former lover of
Daenerys was left in Meereen
at the end of season six
to keep an eye on the city.
We never heard from him again.
Surely his men could have been used
in the battle against
the dead, apparently not.
And what about Ellaria Sand?
At the end of season seven,
Ellaria Sand was left
to watch her daughter die in
front of her in the Red Keep.
We never saw or heard from her again.
Six, unrealistic events.
Yes, I am going to go there.
In a show about dragons,
magic, and the undead,
I'm gonna call out some
unrealistic things that happened.
Don't worry, the irony isn't lost on me.
First of all, let's
talk about how far Arya
must have had to jump
to kill the Night King.
Yep, that looks like a long way.
I know she has skills,
but that seems silly.
How about when Dany
didn't see Euron's ships
from half a mile high?
This unlikely ambush resulted
in Rhaegal being killed
and Dany's chances of taking
King's Landing being reduced.
One of the positives about having a dragon
should be that you can see
things coming, apparently not.
During this ambush, Drogon and
Dany fled from Euron's ships,
but when it came to taking King's Landing,
the pair destroyed his
whole fleet with ease,
along with all the scorpions
on the wall at King's Landing.
Why didn't they just do that before?
Remember when Bronn
aggressively threatened
Tyrion and Jaime with a crossbow?
Well, apparently that was
forgiven pretty easily
following the burning the King's Landing.
What about undead Viserion?
So undead Viserion
burned through the Wall,
which had protected the
Seven Kingdoms for years,
but he couldn't burn
through a mound of stones
to kill Jon Snow.
So No. 7, the changing
of the main villain.
From episode three to six,
we saw three different
main villains: the Night King
at the Battle of Winterfell,
Cersei during episode four and five,
and finally Daenerys in episode six.
This quick switching
between the antagonists
was a little confusing,
and it wasn't helped
by the lack of time for all
of these events to sink in.
Eight, character deaths.
All right, so I think this
show would have actually been
better with more of the
main characters dying.
"Game of Thrones" lost a lot
of of its unpredictability
when it was drawing to a close.
The show has done it over and over again
killing main characters,
yet it seemed pretty obvious
that the key characters
were going to survive
the Battle of Winterfell as it was clear
that their storylines
still needed to play out.
I never felt like there was
a danger that Jon, Dany,
Tyrion, Sansa, or Arya
might die in the battle,
which is something that
just wouldn't have happened
in previous seasons.
Nine, continuity mistakes.
Yes, this season had quite a few.
The most memorable was the coffee cup
in plain sight on the table
after the Battle of Winterfell.
There are also two
modern-day water bottles
on the floor in the scene
before Bran is named king.
Something that many fans
noticed is the inconsistency
of the way that King's
Landing was depicted.
All of these are apparently the same city,
yet they don't look anything alike.
And finally, eagle-eyed viewers spotted
that Daenerys is wearing different wigs
when she arrived at Winterfell
in season eight, episode one.
Let me know in the comments
if you think I missed anything
or if you disagree altogether.